so I told you last week or maybe it was
the week before that when corporate
media makes a big deal out of these faux
and inspirational stories about you know
Jimmy did a fundraiser for his motorized
wheelchair and his classmates came
through for him these really are not
inspirational stories these are really
stories primarily about a broken
dystopian system that forced little
Jimmy to need to do a bake sale for a
medical device which then led to people
who understandably felt so horribly for
Jimmy that they gave Jimmy some of their
money and these stories really have to
stop and fair which is fairness and
accuracy in reporting did a really good
piece about these bogus stories they
call them perseverance porn which is
really a great name for them so here are
some examples
two-year-old Logan Moore needs a walker
insurance wouldn't cover it
Home Depot built one from parts Fox 5 DC
proclaimed this is awesome on Good
Morning America donating vacation time
to new moms is a trendy co-worker baby
shower gift
how lovely wrong it's not lovely okay
this is a terrible system that doesn't
give new moms paid time off they can't
afford paid time off and we've not
decided as a society that this is
something that we're going to take care
of there's a whole bunch of other ones
that were putting up on the screen about
a 12 year old boy who raked leaves to
afford a gravestone for his friend who
died of cancer a 13 year old boy who
sold his xbox and did yard work to buy
his single mom a car so she could get to
work
these are uplifting stories of
individual will in a sense like there's
no doubt about that I'm not denying that
but what they really tell us that is
notable is how truly dystopian our
economic reality has become in the
United States there's no need for these
things to happen in the country right
this is one of the richest countries in
the world as inspirational as we can say
the 12 year olds actions are or as
notable as the resolve of seven-year-old
Jimmy is in order to raise money for his
mom's cancer treatment or whatever it is
a thousand times more disgusting that
it's necessary in our kind
this is optional like if we decided as a
country we're not gonna be allowed in a
way that allows this we're not gonna be
organized in a way that allows this to
happen that is really the most important
thing to me so to avoid the criticism
that I know is coming I know people will
write to me and say David are you saying
that these aren't nice things people are
doing or that we shouldn't applaud them
it's fine people in bad situations
should be doing nice things and we
should recognize that and it's okay to
do that but I read this example on
reddit which is a good one someone gets
caught in the rain and a random stranger
gives them an umbrella that's nice rain
was the problem and the umbrella was the
solution in that case in a similar but
slightly different example if a homeless
person is caught in the rain for years
because they're persistently homeless
and society simply hasn't decided that
we're going to deal with that as an
issue right now and a passerby gives
them an umbrella giving them an umbrella
is still nice but the problem in the
second case is the breakdown of our
systems or the fact that they don't
exist even to begin with to deal with
homelessness as a systemic problem
that's the difference here
friendly 80 year olds who are mowing
lawns for money someone comes along and
buys them a better lawnmower that's
great that's a nice thing to do but why
are so many people unable to retire in
our country and they have to keep
working including mowing lawns out in
the heat at age 80 that's really the
problem and the new lawnmower as nice as
it might be doesn't actually solve the
underlying problem so cover the stories
that's fine but talk about structural
issues and of course corporate media
won't why not
because corporate media has not only a
bias to sensationalism but corporate
media has a bias towards
compartmentalized acute stories that
happen at one point in time rather than
systemic issues that grow or change and
shift and are difficult to cover with a
discrete beginning middle and end this
is why if 30 people died in a terrorist
attack that gets way more coverage than
10,000 starving African children dying
because even if you fix 50%
the starving African children problem
there would still be 5,000 kids who died
that day instead of 10,000 and the story
becomes background it doesn't have a
discrete beginning middle and end in the
way that corporate news basically
requires in order to fill the format
that they've decided is the one that
they're going to carry out so the faux
inspirational stories are okay as long
as we point out what the systemic
problems are corporate media is not
going to do that so at least I'll do my
best to do it for you